hi my name is Arun yadda when I'm a
fifth grader from green rider elementary
right now I'm standing on this mountain
internal park the most beautiful place
in glendale arizona if you visit my home
state arizona there are many sides that
you could see the one that stands out
the most of the Grand Canyon Grand
Canyon National Park of World Heritage
Site encompassing 1.2 million square
miles and this 277 miles long and 10
miles wide making the largest canyon
another side of the scene Arizona's Lake
Powell did you know that Lake Powell the
second largest man-made reservoir in the
United States is located on the colorado
river north of the Grand Canyon it
receives 3 million visitors annual
hiking boating skiing sightseeing and
other things are all are all available
in late hour let me ask you question to
see London Bridge will really go london
right but instead you have to actually
within my home state arizona lemon
bridge was actually taken from london to
Lake Havasu City and reassembled just
the way it was in London week of
absolute near Lake Havasu City is a
perfect the perfect getaway for water
lovers and better lovers of life
most important tip I want to give you
your position stay there for the summer
in bring this R square and most
importantly water if I had a free ticket
to go anywhere in the world I would
definitely go to the Amazon River I'm
really fascinated about the wildlife and
the diverse ecosystems it has the reason
why I want to go there is because I want
to explore the rain forest and the best
choice would be of course the largest
wave birds on earth oh and here's one
reason I definitely want to go there I
will want to see my favorite Raptor the
harpy eagle and my favorite reptile the
Anaconda if I could trade places with
any famous person I'm to Neil Armstrong
I were children because then I could see
the constellation and so watch your body
from the moon even though I'll never
hear the music of the heavens and we
shall have a view of it hey here's one
weird fact I bet you didn't know blood
maintains her body temperature that's
important to other body functions but
can it be used for defense the whole
lizard of Australia's course blood out
of his eyes as a deep in mechanical that
ought to scare the predator away
you